sinon celui-ci va à St
[Musique]
baders je dois sortir d'
ici je dois sortir de cette petite
pièce sortir
[Musique]
discothèque boîte de
nuit
nous
boîte de nuit nous ce qui
se passe
boîte de nuit nous la
nuit nous et
machine à glace  nous voyons des gens de toutes nouvelles
personnes il y a quelque chose à
voir en
boîte de nuit nous en
boîte de nuit oh n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
avec [
Musique] boîte de
nuit nous sommes une boîte de nuit nous
marchons dans [Musique]
boîte de nuit en ville nous sommes en
boîte de nuit nous  marcher comme un
fantôme nous apprenons des danses des danses toutes nouvelles
comme le nucléaire
B
quand nous sommes gentils
en clubing en clubing blanc brillant
oh n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
nuit sauvage
FL oh